IT IS TIME FOR OUR NEXT GAME,
RICH CAT, POOR CAT.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
IF YOU'VE WATCHED OUR SHOW AT
ANY LENGTH YOU KNOW THERE IS NOW
A TUMBLR WHERE PEOPLE POST
RIDICULOUS PICTURES OF CATS,
SURROUNDED BY MONEY CALLED CASH
CATS BECAUSE THESE PEOPLE HAVE A
LOT OF FREE TIME, AND CATS AND
STUFF TO PUT AROUND THEM.
SO I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU A
PICTURE AND YOU HAVE TO TELL ME
IF IT IS FROM A CASH CAT OR IF
IT'S A PICTURE OF CAT BEING
HUMILIATED SOMEWHERE ELSE ON THE
INTERNET, ALL RIGHT?
SO FOR 250 POINTS, YOU SAY
RICH CAT OR POOR CAT.
READY, HERE IS THE FIRST ONE.
RICH CAT, POOR CAT.
YES, AL?
>> POOR CAT.
>> YES, THAT IS A POOR CAT.
OH!
(LAUGHTER)
>> I WONDER WHICH LUCKY LADY
CAUGHT THE CAT.
>> Chris: IT'S THE ONE WITH
THE SCRATCH MARKS ALL OVER HER
FACE.
"I AM GETTING MARRIED NEXT."
JUST BLEEDING.
>> IT'S LIKE A LADY WHO LOVES
"CATHY" COMICS AND SHE GETS TO
MARRY THE CAT.
>> SO ARE WE TO BELIEVE THAT SHE
HAD THAT STRAPPED AROUND HER LEG
A MINUTE AGO?
>> Chris: THE ENTIRE TIME.
YEAH, THE ENTIRE TIME.
ALL RIGHT, NEXT ONE.
RICH CAT, POOR CAT?
ROB?
>> POOR CAT?
>> Chris: YEAH, THAT IS A POOR
CAT.
MEOW!
THAT'S FROM CATS THAT LOOK LIKE
DAVID BOWIE.
(LAUGHTER)
♪ GROUND CONTROL TO MEW-JER
TOM. ♪
(LAUGHTER)
GOD I HATE MYSELF SO MUCH.
>> THAT WAS AMAZING.
THAT LAST CAT, I HAVE NEVER
DONE COCAINE BUT IF I DID I
WOULD LIKE TO BUY IT FROM THAT
LAST CAT.
>> Chris: FROM THE LAST CAT?
YEAH, NICE.
ALL RIGHT, NEXT ONE.
RICH CAT, POOR CAT?
YES, ARDEN.
>> I'M GOING TO GO POOR CAT
BECAUSE IT LOOKS LIKE A TABBY.
>> WELL, IT'S A MISDIRECT THIS
IS, IN FACT, A VERY RICH CAT.
>> WHOA!
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> DO YOU THINK THAT CAT IS
SINGLE?
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: OKAY, FIRST OF ALL
THERE ARE JUST SOME $20s AND
SINGLES SO THAT IS REALLY ABOUT
$300.
$300, AND SOME RIFLES AND A FOUR
LOCO.
>> IT'S ALSO THAT'S NOT A FOUR
LOCO, THAT IS QUITE A FEW FOUR
LOCOS.
>> I SPENT A LOT OF TIME STAGING
THAT.
IT WAS HARD TO GET THE CAT TO
STAND THERE, CHRIS.
>> THAT CAT ALSO KILLED TWO
WOLVES.
>> Chris: OH, MY GOD, IT
TOTALLY DID!
(LAUGHTER)